bienvenidos a esta presentación en donde
vamos a ver el nivel 4 de ecuaciones
lineales ya por fin llegamos al nivel 4
y en esta ocasión quiero ver la
siguiente ecuación 3 sobre x esto quiero
que sea igual a 5 y lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que en esta
ecuación tenemos un gran problema
tenemos a la equis en el denominador en
todas las ecuaciones pasadas' habíamos
tenido a x en el numerador sin embargo
en esta ocasión tenemos a x en el
denominador cómo podemos resolver esta
ecuación y bueno lo primero que hay que
hacer es quitar lo más rápido que se
pueda a la equis del denominador y para
quitar al x del denominador lo que hay
que hacer es multiplicar esta ecuación
de ambos lados por x es decir x que
multiplica a 3 sobre x es igual a 5 que
multiplica x porque porque si yo tengo x
entre x pues x / x evans es 1 entonces
siempre sencillamente del lado izquierdo
me quedaría un 3 estos dos se van y me
queda del lado izquierdo 3 mientras que
lado derecho me queda 5 x igual date
cuenta que la x ya no está en el
denominador y tenemos una ecuación
el nivel 1 es decir 5x igual a 3 y por
lo tanto ahora ya podemos resolver esta
ecuación qué pasa si yo multiplico ambos
lados por un quinto entonces me queda un
quinto por 5 se van solamente me queda x
mientras que el otro lado me queda tres
quintos y date cuenta que ya hemos
resuelto el problema cuando x vale tres
quintos se cumple esta ecuación con la
que empezamos la cual tenía el grave
problema de tener la equis como
denominador pero ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa si lo complicamos un poco más
déjame borrar la pantalla y vamos a ver
un ejemplo un poco más complicado en
donde tengamos a la x es decir a nuestra
incógnita como denominador tengo x + 2
entre x + 1 esto quiero que sea igual a
7 esto quiero que sea igual a 7 y aquí
tenemos un gran problema tenemos a de x
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador que vamos a hacer y bueno la
respuesta es vamos a hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en el ejercicio pasado lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar esta ecuación
de ambos lados de la ecuación por x + 1
x 1 / 1 es lo mismo que x + 1 por esto
que está aquí y del otro lado también 7
entre 1 x x + 1 entre 1 lo estoy
poniendo entre 1 para que nos queda una
multiplicación de quebrados y veas que
este con esta s bahn x + 1 y x + 1 se
van porque uno multiplica y es la otra
vida entonces del lado izquierdo siempre
sencillamente me queda x + 2 mientras
que del lado derecho me quedan 7 que
multiplica a su vez a x + 1 y aquí tengo
x + 2 es igual y este 7 lo voy a
distribuir por todo lo que está dentro
de los paréntesis este es 7 multiplica
todo lo que está dentro de los
paréntesis por lo tanto utilizando la
propiedad distributiva me va a quedar 7
x + 7 y a continuación si yo lo que
quiero despejar a x
voy a restar 7 x de ambos lados de la
ecuación estas son las ecuaciones que
veíamos en el vídeo pasado son las
ecuaciones del nivel 3 y por lo tanto
recuerda que lo que hay que hacer es
pasar todo lo que tenga que ver con la
variable x de un lado de la ecuación
en esta ocasión voy a decidir en el lado
izquierdo y por lo tanto le puede hacer
restar 7x de ambos lados de la ecuación
de tal manera que este 7x
7x se vayan se cancelen y por otro lado
me queda menos 7 x + x lo cual es menos
6 veces x menos 6 x + 2 esto es igual a
estos dos se fueron y solamente me queda
del lado derecho el 7 y bueno ahora
tengo este 2 que me estorban recuerda
que es lo que hay que hacer es restar
todos los lados de la ecuación para que
queden todos los números de lados de la
ecuación y todo lo que tenga que ver con
la incógnita del otro lado de la
ecuación y entonces obtengo menos 6x es
igual a 7 menos dos lo cual es 5 y si
ahora multiplicó por el recíproco de
menos 6 lo cual es menos un sexto ya voy
a obtener el valor de x es decir estamos
en las ecuaciones del nivel 1 en las
ecuaciones fáciles
voy a multiplicar por el recíproco de
ambos lados de la ecuación menos un
sexto menos un sexto y menos un sexto
que multiplica menos 6 estos dos semanas
porque esto me da 1 entonces del lado
izquierdo solamente me queda x mientras
que del lado derecho me queda 5 x menos
un sexto lo cual es menos 5 sextos x es
igual a menos 5 sextos y ya está lo
hemos logrado ya tenemos el valor de x
que satisface esta ecuación
yo sería bastante bueno que tú te dieras
a la tarea de poner este valor de x aquí
en la ecuación original sustituyera
nuestro valor que vamos a encontrar para
comprobar que realmente llegamos a una
igualdad pero bueno vamos a otro
ejercicio otro ejercicio que tenga que
ver con esto que estamos viendo 3 entre
x + 5 quiero que esto sea igual a 8
entre x + 2 ahora si tengo el x 5 en el
denominador de la parte izquierda de
esta ecuación mientras que tengo el x +
2 en el denominador de la parte derecha
de esta ecuación cómo se resuelve esto
pues bueno la idea es más o menos la
misma lo que voy a hacer primero es
quitar el x + 5 del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y para eso voy a multiplicar de
ambos lados de la ecuación por x + 5 por
x + 5 por x + 5 para que estos dos se
vayan y me queda simple y sencillamente
3 del lado izquierda de la ecuación
mientras que del lado derecho no queda 8
que multiplica a su vez a x + 5 pero
esto dividido entre x + 2 porque aquí
tenemos x + 2 que multiplica a 1 y por
lo tanto todavía tenemos a la x en él
pero bueno primero voy a distribuir este
8 para ver que me quedo 3 es igual a 8 x
+ 40 / x 2 y bueno sigo teniendo este x
+ 2 en el denominador ahora para
quitarlo lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar otra vez esta ecuación pero
ahora lo voy a multiplicar por x + 2 x x
+ 2 por x + 2 o por x + 2 / 1 de tal
manera que se pueda cancelar con este x
+ 2 3 que multiplica x + 2 voy a
distribuir el 3 me queda 3 x 6 recuerda
que lo único que estoy haciendo es
usando la propiedad distributiva 3 por x
+ 3 por 2 y del lado derecho que me va a
quedar x + 2 y x2 vámonos entonces
solamente me quedan 8 x + 48 x + 40 / 1
pero pues esto es lo mismo que 8 x unos
40 y ya tengo una ecuación de las mismas
que vimos en el vídeo pasado voy a
restar 8 x de ambos lados de la ecuación
y que me va a quedar pongo menos 8 x del
lado izquierdo menos 8 x del lado
derecho
bueno pues del lado derecho 8 x menos 8
x evans y del lado izquierdo me queda
menos 8 x más 3 x lo cual es menos 5 x
5 x 6 es igual a 40 y bueno ahora voy a
pasar el 6 del otro lado de la ecuación
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es restar
6 de ambos lados de la ecuación menos 6
aquí menos 6 acá la suerte que más 6
menos 6 se van y ya no tengo espacio así
que déjenme ponerlo todo a continuación
por acá y me va a quedar menos seis más
seis pues estos dos se van y solamente
del lado derecho me queda menos 5 x
menos 5 x porque el 6 y el menos seis se
cancelaron mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 40 menos 6 lo cuales 34 y si
ahora lo que quiero es despejar la x y
ya estamos de nuestras ecuaciones del
nivel 1 lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar por el recíproco de menos 5
que es menos un quinto menos un quinto
menos un quinto en queda que x es igual
a menos 34 quintos por que menos un
quinto por menos 5 se van y espero que
no me haya equivocado según yo va todo
en orden y ya estás preparado para
resolver cualquier ecuación del nivel 4
nos vemos pronto